what up guys welcome to the just
probably things youtube channel today
i'm going to be talking about a topic
that has to do with wealth before i
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel ring that notification bell the
way you're going to be notified of my
daily videos
okay so
i grew up in a top
1
of income family so my dad
started a software company when he was
in his early 20s he sold it 25 years
later
and i have nine siblings they can easily
afford them
i'm not going to give you guys a number
but you just have to take my word that
i come from a top like one percent of
income and wealth family
you can look at my youtube channel if
you want proof that's fine um and i want
to talk about a mistake that i see
people that come into money quickly
make um this isn't
hate
actually kind of it's more criticism
i'll give it criticism
rich people look down on you
wealthy people i will say not rich
because rich to me is like i got money
overnight i got success overnight but
people that are wealthy and stay wealthy
look down on people that flex their
money on social media
i know someone worth probably about a
hundred million
that man drove the same car for 20 years
the richest and most successful people
that i know do not flex their money in
everyone's faces
they might have five houses right but
they're not gonna post them on social
media
brag about how successful they are
buying that house like nobody would even
know that they had five houses unless
they asked the kids and the wife
sometimes do flex right i mean i posted
my parents house on social media
but you don't see my parents bragging
about that because when you're secure in
your success and your money and you know
you have power and influence
you do not need
to flat to flash your lifestyle on
social media and when you do see rich
people flat like flashing their
lifestyle it is usually like
one a thousand
one out of a thousand things they could
afford
and that's rare i'm telling you the
actual workhorse is the actual success
driven people
that
not only have
you know money but they have power
influence
they don't move like a lot of these
influencers move
and
it's interesting because i see a lot of
like young influencers shoot themselves
in the foot with the way that they carry
themselves
but let me know in the comments if you
guys agree or you disagree just the
thought i had today
don't forget to subscribe i'll talk to
you later